just felt like
this season
wasn't it was challenging for everyone
but man i felt like it was time i felt
like it was time you know i kind of knew
maybe heading into training camp this
might but you don't you you know you
don't share that with anyone you think
well let's see how the season goes and
we're working hard and
and
i felt the time was right for me i felt
the time was right and it's something
that i i've been thinking about
you know i think that
look you have close friends in the
industry
i've lost a few close friends in this
industry in the last two or three years
um
and also
you know they're
forget football there's other things
spending more time there's a lot of
sacrifices you make and so
not many get to choose their terms
and
i looked at it as an opportunity also to
to see my kids more to travel some more
to to get in better shape to
there's an attrition
two in the morning and and i know i hear
people say well you don't have yeah i
get it but i need to that that's the way
it works for me
and
i think the attention to details are so
important that it can be exhausting and
so i felt
as this season was winding down um
that it was the right thing in the last
week and a half
yeah i'm comfortable with that
[Music]
two
one
[Applause]
hi welcome to the safety blitz starting
a two-time super bowl champ rodney
harrison so we just heard that sound
right there as sean payton decides that
he is going to step away from football
and it just you could hear on the
burnout if you want to call that in his
voice those long pauses trying to decide
exactly how he wanted to put it rodney
harrison bit surprising with this one
how did you hear the news that sean
payton's going to be stepping down
happy for sean payton
it's just
i was really excited for um sean payton
my my
thing is
it's not working right i'm sorry but i
was really excited for sean payton
because it's really sounded like he was
a guy that was really tired he was beat
down obviously they're over the cap um
70 million
you think about drew brees retiring them
not having a quarterback it's just a
tough situation i'm happy for him
because he mentioned the important
things in life football is not
everything he talked about his kids
getting in better shape he talked about
stress because that job comes with a
great deal of stress but also you know
when you look at sean payton and i've
been to some of his practices when he's
performing before a game and this guy
pays attention to detail he goes over
his routine
same thing with drew brees and their
quarterback so for me to sit back and be
able to see sean payton and see that he
wants to do other things whether it's
television spend time with his family i
think it's a very smart thing for him to
do
you spend around these nfl head coaches
the more you realize the challenge that
it is and then when you have somebody
like drew brees who he was so close to
and you get to go through the grind with
somebody that you really like and
respect and you have a relationship with
that extends beyond football i think it
eases it out this is the quarterback
league i mean this is the quarterback fl
and if you don't have one of those top
10 quarterbacks to try to win games in
this league is so close to impossible
and losing in this league will suck the
soul out of you and we've seen that i
mean look at urban meyer this year and
what losing did to him i mean he just
basically crumbled i mean this whole
thing fell apart on the fly and so when
you're used to winning and man how many
games has it felt like the saints have
no chance they have no quarterback this
guy's hurt that guy's hurt a million
cove cases and they go in there and win
and that's coaching so sean payton is
one of the in my opinion top five
coaches in the nfl it's going to be very
hard for them to replace that level of
coach but you could just hear in the way
he was talking that what he's done in
the nfl has sucked so much out of the
rest of his life and he was ready to go
find some of that now in his you know
high 50s he didn't want to let all these
years get away from him and i respect
that
and basically what's going to happen is
he's going to take a year off he's going
to do whatever he he wants to do
television or whatever he may want to do
and he's going to re feel he's going to
come back and feel like he's rejuvenated
i mean it's going to feel like he's got
a new leash on life because he's been
away from the game for a year he's going
to miss it then he's going to get back
involved sean payton is a football coach
at the end of the day he's not a tv guy
he's not going to be a guy that just
sits at home and just looks at football
on sunday and thursday and monday he's a
football guy he wants to teach men and i
saw him firsthand many times teaching
these guys and he's an excellent
football coach i agree with you so let's
talk about maybe the teams that could
potentially be
a landing spout for them i mean come on
now remember a couple years ago it was
rumors about the dallas cowboys don't
you think that would be a perfect fit
him and dak prescott to take over this
team in this offense
do i would say that's very possible
maybe take one year maybe two years and
then come back and coach dallas and who
knows what may be available at that
point so let's hear from coach payton
here's what he said about what might be
next and then the speculation can begin
here's what he said
honestly as i sit here today
and this is okay
i don't know what's next and look i i i
read the reports and i understand
i've not spoken to anyone from
a media outlet relative to
doing television or radio maybe maybe
that opportunity arises
but every time i read something that
says like he's in line for this job i'll
i'll call my agent don and i'll say don
did you hear something because i have
not heard anything
and that's okay
um
i think i'd like to do that i think i'd
be pretty good at it
but
so stepping
stepping outside like in the cold
weather today and being a little
uncomfortable professionally or from a
career standpoint is okay
i don't like the word retirement mr b
didn't like it either he always said you
know retirement's overrated we get sold
this whole
image of retirement by these investment
groups on tv and golf courses and
retirement and and so
um
yeah i
i'm
i still have a vision for for doing
things in football and and i'll be
honest with you
that might be coaching again at some
point i don't think it's this year i
think maybe in the future but that's not
where my heart is right now
it's not at all
it sure sounded like he wanted a job in
tv right there didn't it i mean that
that was shocking
he wants to work in tv
he does
he's taking this opportunity with a huge
platform instead of talking about you
know he talked about retirement all that
other stuff but he had to make sure that
he plugged himself and said hey whether
it's tv or radio so he's basically
telling all the network executives like
i'm i'm free i'm available i think i'm
going to be really good at it and i'm
here and i'm available if you want me
basically that's what he's saying
and who better would he have to be able
to bounce ideas off of what that would
be like than drew brees i'm sure they've
already said that they had a lengthy
conversation where he just informed drew
of what he was thinking about doing some
of those things so we'll see what the
heck ends up happening with sean payton
but i just think that grind of the day
today the 6 a.m waking up he's ready to
take a little break from that prioritize
a little family but it does sound like
the idea of truly retiring sounds
miserable to him doesn't it it's like
the idea of doing nothing sounds more
miserable than what he was doing but
he's trying to figure out what that
in-between land is that's going to bring
him a little bit of joy and a little bit
of football in his life which it sounds
like he needs more than air to breathe
dude
if we retired it would be miserable for
all of us because i mean nobody's meant
to retire and do nothing you have to
keep your mind stimulated you have to do
something you have to give back to your
society you just have to you know get
involved so i don't worry about sean
payton he's a smart dude he's got a
gazillion dollars in the bank we don't
worry about sean payton he's going to do
fine on television his biggest challenge
after that one year he's going to have
to decide whether he's calling games or
whether he's in the studio like do i
want to go back on the football field
and i guarantee you if the right
opportunity opens up he's going to be
done with that booth he's going to be
back on the sidelines but coaches get
burnt out just like players get burnt
out and i'm so happy because over the
course of my time with football i've
seen a lot of coaches basically eat
their way and really just not take care
of themselves right into like cancer and
to a whole bunch of other different
debilitating diseases and stuff like
that so it's good that he's focused on
you know his health and his family
all right and we've seen so many times
you go to the booth for a year or two
okay now a job opens up it's the right
job now all of a sudden you're back in
it we'll see how it all plays out but it
definitely sounded like tv maybe in the
near near future for sean payton
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports